this is an infinite chess mural that i
designed
why is it infinite
because every time you zoom in by a
factor of two you get the same full
pattern repeating again forever and ever
at least you do in theory
i want to show you some of the cool
mathematics that went into making this
we're going to start by drawing just one
spiral
the first line a bit starts here and
we're going to make sure that it touches
this diagonal line somewhere but where
our rule is going to be that it touches
that diagonal line
at a right angle we're just going to
follow that same rule all the way around
so the next line
also meets this line
at a right angle
and so does this one
etc
etc
but we need more spirals and remember we
need the next spiral in to be exactly
half of the size of the previous one
so how we're going to do that well
there's actually an easy way to do this
if we measure
the distance from here
to the center
we want to make sure that the new spiral
starts at exactly
half of that distance
make the next spiral half of that etc
for this to exactly work out we need to
make sure that the first spiral
comes back and joins at exactly one of
these points so can you figure out how
to mathematically prove that this is
what happens
here's one last thing to deal with i
really want this to look like a chess
board because in my favorite book alice
finds herself in a giant game of chess
i also really like richard feynman's
analogy that doing physics is like
trying to learn chess by just watching
people play but for this to look like a
chessboard every segment needs to have a
neighbor of opposite color and
diagonally touch a segment of the same
color
how can you guarantee that this will
happen for every one of these segments
i had a great time figuring out the
answer to these kinds of questions when
i was playing around with this fractal
and i hope you do too
the less fun bit was figuring out how on
earth to get such a finicky pattern
precisely on the wall and so that's why
i bought this 600 machine to cut out the
pattern
and five days later with the help of my
brother and his questionable but
effective methods we got it onto the
wall
i'm making youtube videos full time now
so
expect to see this wall behind me a
whole bunch more